have you talked to Eduardo Luna about
this because you know he feels that this
that the great secret of ayahuasca that
remains to be discovered is what it's
like if you keep these specialized diets
and load your system with serotonin via
plantains there is a live actively
unblended yes and there is a specialized
diet and often shamanic power is judged
by how long a man claims to have kept
this diet now this is an Arian not none
of us have explored rare enough here is
the person whoever I went into it in
small way he did it for about ten days
or so so here's a frontier for self
experiment
what is it what is a stable high start
well the diet is plantains which are
these cook able bananas and a very
little bit of fish and yuca and that's
basically it no greens no sugar no
alcohol an extremely minimal diet I mean
almost despair as it to be no really no
fruit no anything except those things
and a lot of ayahuasca in in isolation I
mean daily dose yes and living in a
little Hut being served by a child who's
the only if there's no cell it'll do you
know that contact uh-huh
they they spit no it's not just that
they speak of the spirit as a cloud
which because there is a very strong
animist beliefs which you can find
pretty easy to share when you get in
there and they call it the mother is a
plant I don't know why but la madre de
la plan to DC the mother of the plants
will tell you and there's so much
interest me is that in Western culture
the idea
yong-man mythology has to go out and and
get rid of leave this mother in order to
and leave all the feminine in order to
become strong and be a man well they
didn't mean this agent agent number of
tribes in South America I think but it's
a brief period
well this experience of dissolution is
experience of dissolution into the
maternal matrix
I'm sure it's felt like that it's a it's
a dying and of being reborn and surely
these early people and people on that
level of culture today must have
experienced it that way as a death and a
rebirth and boiled
his mana dissipation they roasted it
sometimes just sometimes for us to never
fried the really that never fire the
enemy cuz haven't any fat jungle one
reason that India is sort of one of the
reasons I think you said have you ever
seen a really fat Indian I haven't and
first they haven't probably haven't got
the genes for it but also they their
food is practically fat-free because
jungle animals are running they have its
lean meat the fish they have the very
few fact they should and they have no
source for fat they don't use the palm
pads
except when they eat certain palm fruits
and so they don't fry anything yes
people have the wrong idea about the
jungle in the sense that people think
well it's so so much vegetation there
must be a lot of food but you see you
can still you can starve but have the
evolution has been so tight for so long
that no excess protein is being produced
and if it is produced a bird a monkey
and ant is gobbling it up long before
you get near it and then you gobble up
the bird monkey over and that's right
especially those add to the big behind
yeah
wait were you a honey we Mui Nani they
stink straws down into the ant hills and
all the ants latch on and these moon on
a children would pull these things out
of the ant hills and put the ants in
bowls of water and smash it up with it
no I haven't seen that yeah it was
delicious
I can take my sorrow and heartache it
love it don't you
I learned to like it Misato is this
foaming yuca beer that after you've
walked miles through the jungle and you
arrived at some place the first thing
else they meet you with a foaming go
or and of this stuff and it's chewed by
the elderly women in the village let's
cook dilka chewed and they spit it but
the mouth enzymes the sugars work on it
and then it's fermented and and if you
really want to gain their confidence you
knock back a huge guard of this stuff
and then call for more yes and you have
them actually if you can eat yogurt it
tastes quite good hahaha
and you just have to go to the thought I
used to repeat it as some people repeat
their beads and athletes the
fermentation process destroys all
pathogenic bacteria the family destroys
a favour
see ya over and over a homer I didn't
know that so my mantra was it is good to
challenge the immune system it is good
to challenge the immune system
[Music]
[Music]